Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbandes für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 7. Ausgabe in der Gesprächsserie hier über zahlreiche Aspekte, die die Wissenschaft berühren, direkt/indirekt und im Fokus der heutigen Ausgabe steht die Sprache. Um genauer zu sein, die deutsche Sprache. Und als Gesprächspartner dafür begrüße ich Peter Eisenberg. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Pritlove.
Sie sind Sprachwissenschaftler. Haben Ihre aktive Zeit jetzt schon hinter sich gebracht. Von wann bis wann haben Sie das so ausgeübt?
Emeritiert worden bin ich im Jahr 2005 und mit der Sprachwissenschaft habe ich 1969.
Also blicken Sie schon auf einige Erfahrung zurück. Zuletzt waren Sie in der Universität Potsdam vor allem aktiv, ist richtig?
Ja, das war meine letzte Professur, vorher war ich an der freien Universität in Berlin und in Hannover.
Aber angefangen hat es ja eigentlich alles ganz anders. Sprache stand nicht unbedingt im Zentrum Ihrer Ausbildung oder?
Nein, die Sprache stand nicht im Zentrum, sondern die Idee einer Dolmetscherrolle zwischen der Technik auf der einen Seite und der Musik auf der anderen Seite. Ich habe ein Musikstudium an der Hochschule für Musik in Berlin absolviert und ein Nachrichtentechnik/Akustik-Studium an der Technischen Universität und das Berufsziel war Tonmeister. Das habe ich auch eine Weile ausgeübt, aber dann habe ich es mir anders überlegt.
Was hat denn das umfasst, Tonmeister zu sein damals?
Es gab damals erst ganz wenige Stellen in Deutschland, in der alten Bundesrepublik Deutschland, an der Tonmeister ausgebildet wurden. Das ging entweder so, dass man ein volles Musikstudium absolviert hat, zum Beispiel an der Musikhochschule in Detmold und das konnte man auch an der Musikhochschule in Berlin machen und dann wurde nebenbei Technik studiert oder man wurde eben Diplomingenieur mit einer Vollausbildung in Nachrichtentechnik/Studiotechnik und dann Informatik, die entstand damals gerade. Und machte ein Zusatzstudium an der Hochschule für Musik mit den Fächern, im Wesentlichen natürlich Gehörbildung, Instrumentenkunde, Tonsatz, Komposition, Partiturspiel, ein Instrument musste man auch studieren. Das war so ein bisschen ähnlich, wie die Schulmusikerausbildung.
Aber den Bogen jetzt von Musik bis zur Informatik, den finde ich ja schon recht abenteuerlich. Also wie kommt denn die Nachrichtentechnik da jetzt so ohne weiteres ins Spiel. Ist jetzt nicht unbedingt eine typische Kombination gewesen damals oder?
Nein, das war natürlich eine sehr seltene Kombination, weil man ja beides gleichzeitig machen musste. Man musste auch eine Aufnahmeprüfung an der Musikhochschule machen, ähnlich wie die Schulmusiker. Und hatte dann regelmäßig dort sein Curriculum zu absolvieren mit allem drum und dran. Und an der technischen Universität hat das überhaupt niemanden interessiert, was man zusätzlich noch gemacht hat. Man hat natürlich im Rahmen des Nachrichtentechnikstudiums damals schon Differenzierungsmöglichkeiten gehabt. Zum Beispiel war ein prominentes Fach in Berlin „Technische Akustik“ und der Chef dieses Lehrstuhls war zum Beispiel verantwortlich für die Akustik der neuen Philharmonie, die damals gerade gebaut wurde. Und dort hat man sehr viel Phonetik gelernt. Physikalische Phonetik, artikulatorische Phonetik und alles was dazu gehörte. Und das kommt einem Tonmeister sehr zu Gute, übrigens auch einem Sprachwissenschaftler.
Ja.
Wenn er darüber genau Bescheid weiß, was da eigentlich passiert physikalisch und was dem physiologisch zugrunde liegt.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, aber den Bogen zur Nachrichtentechnik bekomme ich jetzt noch nicht so richtig. Was war denn da Ihr Interesse, das auch noch zu verfolgen?
Nein, das war einfach der einzige Studiengang, den es gab.
Ach so, der war sozusagen in dieser Kombination wurde er so angeboten.
Der wurde vorgeschrieben.
Das eine zu machen, kriegte man das andere noch mit drauf.
Genau, das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Die Fakultät für Elektrotechnik an der Technischen Universität Berlin hatte sich erst kürzlich von Maschinenbau getrennt und hatte zwei Hauptzweige. Das war die Starkstromtechnik, also Elektromotoren, Transformatoren großer Art, Leitungsbau und so was und eben die Nachrichtentechnik. Das war im Wesentlichen, als ich angefangen habe, auch das Telefon. Und der Anfang der Halbleitertechnik und das wurde dann immer schneller.
Daraus erklärt es sich im Prinzip, weil damals so Telefon, Audio, Akustik, Elektro, alles im Wesentlichen ja ein Ding war.
Genau Tonbänder.
Und natürlich auch Radio.
Ja, ganz große Probleme die Tonbandtechnik. Gleichlauf bei den alten Tonbandgeräten und so was. Das kann man sich heute alles gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Alles analog.
Ja alles analog. Genau. Das heißt so das Digitale in dem Sinne war eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Es fing an.
Es fing an. Ich habe noch an der Z2 gerechnet. An der alten Zuse, die noch mit Elektromagnetik alter Art bestückt war. Da konnte man noch das Ohr dranhalten und hat noch die Relais klicken gehört.
Echt die Z2 sogar?
Ja.
Dieser Prototyp. Interessant, wow. Jetzt bin ich neidisch. So und dann? Also ich meine, das haben Sie dann abgeschlossen. Das heißt dann waren Sie Diplomingenieur oder?
Diplomingenieur ja.
Okay.
Und konnte mich auch Tonmeister nennen. Und habe dann eine Weile an verschiedenen Rundfunkstationen gearbeitet. Erst als Praktikant, dann so ein bisschen mehr, zum Beispiel beim Hessischen Rundfunk. Damals war Dean Dixon der Chef des Radiosymphonieorchesters in Frankfurt. Und der Herr Zender spielte eine große Rolle, der heute immer noch sehr bedeutend in der Kammermusik ist. Und dann habe ich aber schließlich eine Spielzeit lang hier in Berlin im Theater der freien Volksbühne in der Schaberstraße habe ich den Ton gemacht. Das war eine sehr anspruchsvolle Aufgabe und sehr interessant. Da musste man sehr vielseitig sein, also so was wie Play Strindberg oder Sean O'Casey, alle möglichen großen Aufführungen, in diesem großen und sehr gut ausgestatteten Theater. Tschechow „Der Kirschgarten“
Also den Ton für die Wiedergabe, nicht jetzt für die Aufnahme.
Nein, richtig die Bühnenausstattung, mit allem was dazu gehört. Und das habe ich eine Spielzeit lang mit großer Freude gemacht, mir aber dann überlegt, dass ich das nicht mein ganzes Leben lang machen wollte. So einfach war das.
Ja.
Und es war die Zeit, in der die ganze Universitätslandschaft in Bewegung war. Das war nach der Bildungskatastrophe von Herrn Picht und nach der oder während noch der 68er Bewegung, in deren Folge ja die deutschen Universitäten sehr stark expandiert haben. Überall gab es Neugründungen, nicht nur in Nordrhein-Westfalen, aber dort besonders. Die Universitäten wurden ausgebaut, wurden größer. Der Anteil der Abiturienten an den Jahrgängen fingen an, zu wachsen. Man sprach von der Ausschöpfung der Bildungsreserven, die notwendig sei und hat alles mögliche dafür getan, um sozusagen die höhere Bildung und die universitäre Bildung zu verbreitern. Das heißt, es gab dort für Leute, die halbwegs wussten, was sie wollten, sehr gute Lebenschancen. Sehr gute, große Beweglichkeit, das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Wenn jemand so wie ich als Diplomingenieur heute jemandem erzählen würde, ich brauche jetzt aber unbedingt ein Sprachwissenschaftsstudium, dann würde der sagen, du hast doch alles. Was willst du denn? Sei mal froh, dass du bei Telefunken angestellt wirst oder so. Damals war das anders. Wenn man seine Sache fertig gemacht hat, dann hat man sofort ein Stipendium gefunden. Habe ich gemacht. Ich war in gewisser Weise auch ein bisschen privilegiert, ich war Stipendiat des evangelischen Studienwerks und die haben sich gekümmert. Es gab aber eine ganze Reihe von Leuten, die ähnliche Karrieren gemacht haben. Als dann die Sprachwissenschaft wirklich etabliert wurde in den 60er Jahren – 70er Jahren, erste Hälfte der 70er Jahre – setzte sie sich nur zum geringen Teil aus in der Rolle gefärbten Sprachwissenschaftlern alter Art zusammen. Meine Kollegen kamen aus der Theologie, aus der Physik. Mein Doktorvater war Physiker von Hause aus, was die Kommunikation wesentlich erleichtert hat. Ist ja klar. Aber es gab eine ganze Reihe von Naturwissenschaftlern. Es gab Geisteswissenschaftler, es gab Sozialwissenschaftler. So Leute wie Konrad Ehlich, Konrad Ehlich war Sozialwissenschaftler und Theologe. Dieter Wunderlich war Physiker von Hause aus.
Was erklärt das? Dieses breite Feld an der Stelle, weil jetzt einfach so viel Interesse an Sprachwissenschaft auf einmal existierte und es für alle anderen Bereiche sozusagen eine gute Ergänzung darstellt?
Genau. Es gab einen Moment in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte der Bundesrepublik, in der die Sprachwissenschaft so etwas wie eine Schlüsselrolle zugeschrieben wurde. Zum Verständnis gesellschaftlicher Prozesse, sozialer Prozesse, Entwicklungsprozesse überhaupt und zum Verständnis der technischen Entwicklungen. Und das ging so schnell, dass die Sprachwissenschaft etwa neben der Literaturwissenschaft und der Literaturgeschichte innerhalb der Philologien etabliert wurde und das ging so schnell, dass Sprachwissenschaftler auch in der Industrie gesucht wurden. Nicht nur von IBM, sondern auch von anderen großen Firmen, dass etwa auch die Werbungssprache auch, die Sprache der Werbung professionalisiert wurde, weil man verstehen wollte, was man da eigentlich richtig machen muss, um die Leute ordentlich hinters Licht zu führen sprachlich. Also es gab auf ganz verschiedenen Gebieten den Glauben daran, dass wenn man die Sprache in der Kiste hat, dann hat man vieles da mit drin. Und die Folge war natürlich, dass die Universitäten sich um die wenigen Sprachwissenschaftler, die es gab im Nachwuchs, gerissen haben und dass Leute mit diesem Interesse aus allen möglichen Disziplinen in diese Disziplin gedrängt haben.
Wie muss man das verstehen? Also vielleicht ist das jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen ein Blick in den damaligen Zeitgeist. Ich meine, wir reden jetzt so von den 70er Jahren. Das Fernsehen war auf einmal sehr präsent, also hat zumindest in den 70er Jahren eine deutlich stärkere Rolle eingenommen, als noch kurz vorher. Das heißt so diese öffentliche Ausstrahlung, die Wirkung von Medien hat sich verstärkt. Das erklärt sicherlich jetzt einen Teil dieses Interesse. Gerade im Hinblick auf Werbung, was Sie ja schon meinten. Aber Sie sagten ja auch, man versprach sich auch ein Verständnis der technischen Entwicklung davon. Wie lässt sich das erklären?
Also dazu gehörte zum Beispiel das Aufkommen der Großrechner. Also der wirklichen Elektronenrechner. Nach dem Zuse Rechnern den ersten. Die berühmte IBM 36067 füllte große Räume mit Geräten, die aussahen wie Kleiderschränke. Und es gab …
Das waren auch wirklich so die Rechenmaschinen der Wirtschaft für lange Zeit noch, bis weit in die 80er Jahre hinein.
Ja genau so ist es. Aber es gab alle möglichen Träume und Behauptungen. Etwa im Bereich der künstlichen Intelligenz und im Bereich der automatischen Übersetzungen und in anderen Anwendungsbereichen. Letzten Endes geisterte so etwas durch die Landschaft wie die Idee von der sprechenden Maschine. Es gab das sogenannte Touring-Kriterium, das besagte, gewonnen hat derjenige, der den ersten Rechner baut, der so spricht, dass man ihn nicht von einem Menschen unterscheiden kann. Und da steckte die ganze Problematik drin, die wir bis heute noch haben. Dieser Rechner wird nur von außen betrachtet. Es wird nur betrachtet, was er tut, wie er spricht und was darin passiert interessiert keinen. Das war die eine Linie, sozusagen die behaviouristische, was siehst du, was der macht. Die andere Linie, die dem entgegengesetzt war, ganz anders dachte, sprach eben vom Elektronengehirn im engeren Sinn. Dass in the long run, also auf die Dauer doch so etwas ähnliches machen sollte, wie das menschliche Gehirn. Also eine Simulation kognitiver Vorgänge, die man beim Menschen kennt oder die man ihm unterstellt. Das waren die beiden Linien. Und das ist bis heute im Prinzip so geblieben. Das jetzt im Einzelnen auszuführen würde sehr lange dauern. Und warum es dann auch so gekommen ist, wie es jetzt gekommen ist, auch. Das lag im Wesentlichen eben daran, dass die Computer immer größer und immer schneller wurden, so dass dieser Simulationsgedanke immer weiter in den Hintergrund gerückt ist und dann durch etwas anderes, wie die Netzwerktechnik letzten Endes, ersetzt worden ist. Aber was mich damals vollkommen fasziniert hat und auch an die Sprache gebracht hat, das war ein geniales Programm meines Mentors am MIT am Massachusetts Institute of Technology, in dem ich zwei Semester verbracht habe. Gerade in dieser Wechselzeit. Das war Joseph Weizenbaum, der das berühmte Computerprogramm ELIZA geschrieben hat. Das war ein Programm, man unterhielt sich mit dem Computer nicht über Mikrofon, soweit war man nicht mit der Spracherkennung, sondern über eine Fernschreibmaschine, über eine Schreibmaschine. Das war aber so gut gemacht dieses Programm, dass man den Eindruck hatte, man spricht mit einem Psychologen. Diese bekannte amerikanische psychotherapeutische Theorie steckte dahinter. Der fragte einen nach irgendetwas, man antwortete, dann kam die nächste Frage und irgendwann sagte man zu dem, der neben einem stand, geh mal bitte raus, das wird mir jetzt hier zu intim mit dem. Und dann haben wir uns das Programm angeguckt, das war einfach genial.
Ja wir reden von Joseph Weizenbaum, Pionier der künstlichen Intelligenz.
Ja, das Programm war so einfach, das kann sich überhaupt keiner vorstellen und intelligent war es schon gar nicht. Es war strohdoof und wir haben uns dann einen Sport draus gemacht, es mit möglichst wenig Zügen aufs Kreuz zu legen, so dass es dann irgendwie was sagen musste wie, i`m afraid, i don´t understand you oder so was. Dann war es fertig. Das war so ein Sport von Leuten, die sich da so ein bisschen auskannten. Aber das Touring-Kriterium war erst mal erfüllt und für mich, der anfing, sich intensiv für Sprache zu interessieren und damals auch Linguistik war das am Massachusetts Institute of Technology bei Noam Chomsky studiert hat, für mich war das prägend, weil mir klar wurde, dass unser Begriff von Sprachverstehen eigentlich nicht viel besagt. Wenn ich den Eindruck habe, ich verstehe, was die Maschine sagt, aber die meint gar nichts, dann gibt einem das schon sehr zu denken. Im Bezug auf das Vertrauen in die Tatsache, dass man nun einigermaßen gut versteht, was der andere, mit dem man sich gerade unterhält, der keine Maschine, sondern ein Mensch ist, was der nun wirklich gemeint hat. Also das war so ein Schlüsselerlebnis für mich.
Jetzt versuche ich mich schon wieder so ein bisschen in die Zeit rein zu versetzen. Also ELIZA ist 66 glaube ich von Joseph Weizenbaum, ich weiß nicht, wie lange dann letztlich daran gearbeitet wurde, wahrscheinlich gar nicht so lange, aber so in der Zeit ist es entstanden. Zwei Jahre später gab es dann schon den sprechenden Computer in der Science Fiction Kubrik mit 2001 Odyssee im Weltall, sicherlich ein prägender Film auch für Sie gewesen, nehme ich mal an.
Für mich ja. Movie Night war das, Freitag Abend, wurde am MIT gezeigt. Und es roch nach Haschisch natürlich furchtbar. Und als er den Knochen hob und damit seinem Mitmenschen den Schädel einschlug, schrien sie alle, die erste Dissertation, die Hebelwirkung. Das war so, tatsächlich das war so.
Genau und darin drückt sich ja im Prinzip das ganze, also auch in dem Film letztlich, aber auch glaube ich, in der Auseinandersetzung jetzt hier mit Sprache, so dieses, die Menschheit entwickelt sich weiter, man lernt Werkzeuge analytisch einzusetzen und letzten Endes dringt man in Bereiche vor, die noch nie ein Mensch zuvor gesehen hat. Der von Ihnen erwähnte Noam Chomsky, der war dann damals der Chef beim MIT, sehe ich das richtig?
Der war Chef der Linguistik.
Der Linguistik. Und da liefen aber einige Lingu... also Linguistik und Sprachwissenschaft ist das das gleiche oder ist das nur ein andere Name dafür?
In Amerika heißt es Linguistics, in Deutschland wurde ja die Sprachwissenschaft sozusagen neu gegründet, weil aus verschiedenen Gründen. Die alte Sprachwissenschaft, die hier existierte, hatte eben mit dieser eher technischen und streng theoretischen Seite nicht viel zu tun. Die war außerdem sehr belastet durch ihre Vergangenheit. Und die neue Disziplin wurde als Linguistik eingeführt und das war auch ein Begriff, der gegen die alte Sprachwissenschaft gerichtet war. Und war in diesem Sinne ein Kampfbegriff. Und als wir dann aber zehn Jahre später unsere eigene wissenschaftliche Gesellschaft gegründet haben, haben wir sie deutsche Gesellschaft für Sprachwissenschaft genannt. Weil das Wort Linguistik auch eine problematische Verwendungsdomäne im Amerikanischen hat. Also Linguistic heißt auch sprachlich und nicht nur sprachwissenschaftlich. Das ist einer der Gründe. Aber wir wollten auch umfassend sein wissenschaftlich und wir wollten nicht nur diese neue amerikanisierte Disziplin in Deutschland haben, sondern wir wollten sie haben, aber eben auch anderes, was es in Amerika nicht gab. Insofern ist es dann doch bei Sprachwissenschaft geblieben. Meiner Meinung nach glücklicherweise.
Was hat Sie denn ursprünglich zum MIT gebracht? Das habe ich jetzt gar nicht so verstanden.
Ach das war ganz einfach. Ich habe hier in Berlin, als ich meine Prüfungen hatte und mir dann ein bisschen die Hörner abgestoßen hatte am Theater, da habe ich mir eben überlegt intensiv und lange, was ich denn nun wirklich mein Leben lang machen wollte und daraus da kam eben die Sprachwissenschaft bei raus, in Konkurrenz zur Jurisprudenz übrigens, das wäre die Alternative gewesen.
Das Tonmeistertum war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon ausgeschieden?
Ja, das wollte ich nicht. Das hatte ich ja. Und damals kursierten so Sprüche wie, warum machen die Arbeiter keine Revolution? Weil wir es ihnen nicht richtig erklären. Das war nicht meine Sicht der Dinge, aber das war auch ein Ausdruck dieser Hochschätzung der Sprache und ihren vielfältigen Funktionen in der Gesellschaft, eben von der Technik bis ins soziale hinein. Auf der anderen Seite gab es eben zum Beispiel diese soziolinguistischen Theorien, die damals sehr stark wurden, zum Teil auch aus Amerika importiert, über so Fragen wie, was passiert eigentlich in den Hirnen von Leuten, die nicht so sprechen, wie die Mittelschicht. Die also nicht die ganze deutsche Sprache im Sinne ihrer komplexen Syntax und der Größe ihres Wortschatzes zur Verfügung haben. Der sogenannte restringierte Code, den die Arbeiter angeblich gesprochen haben, der wurde von einer sehr dogmatischen und sehr wichtigen Fraktion so interpretiert, dass, wenn man den Leuten die Mittelschichtsprache beibringt, dann denken sie auch wie die Mittelschicht. Dieser Zusammenhang von Sprache – kann man nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen - dieser Zusammenhang von Sprache und Denken, der wurde als sehr eng angesehen, aber natürlich ist die Sprache nur ein Symptom. Und man fing dort in großem Umfang an, Symptom zu kurieren. Auch das wieder nur ein Beispiel dafür, wie weit damals das Interesse an der Sprache reichte. Und für mich, der aus der Technik kam und auch Algebra gemacht hatte und viel Akustik gemacht hatte, formale Sprachen gemacht hatte. Ich habe eine Reihe von Programmiersprachen beherrscht. Logikkalkül das war für eigentlich ganz alltäglich. Für den war es eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, da zu starten und in die Sprachwissenschaft, in die Wissenschaft von den natürlichen Sprachen einzusteigen. Die Basis war also in gewisser Weise schon vorhanden. Und das hat dann mit den ganzen gesellschaftlichen Randbedingungen und dem politischen Denken, was in meiner Generation, damals in Berlin zumindest, sehr verbreitet war, den Ausschlag gegeben. Ich versuche es jetzt mal. Auch die automatische Übersetzung, auch die künstliche Intelligenz scheitert daran, solange man nicht sehr sehr sehr viel mehr über die Sprache weiß. Und ich habe dann auch noch eine Weile so ein bisschen geschwankt, ob ich nicht in diese eher technische Richtung reingehen sollte und dann war die Philologie aber so faszinierend plötzlich. Ich habe auch ein altsprachliges Gymnasium besucht irgendwie. War so faszinierend, dass ich mich daran festgebissen habe.
An der Philologie?
Ja. Richtig, in der Philologie.
Wie verhält sich Philologie zu Sprachwissenschaft?
Die Sprachwissenschaft hat in den Einzelphilologien einen bestimmten Platz. Eine Einzelphilologie hat klassischerweise zwei Abteilungen, die Literatur und die Sprache. Also wenn Sie Englisch studieren, dann studieren Sie englische Sprache, mehr oder weniger linguistisch elaboriert.
Und die Literatur.
Und die englische Literatur. So ist es im Französischen und im Prinzip auch im Deutschen.
Okay. Das heißt das stand dann auch im Zentrum Ihrer Forschung.
Das stand im Zentrum. Ja. Die Faszination ging eigentlich von der konstruktiven Seite, die so eine Sprache, wie das Deutsche, hat, wenn man sich in die Struktur sozusagen rein begibt, ging von dieser konstruktiven Seite aus. Und die Idee der generativen Schule, also der Grammatik, die Noam Chomsky vertreten hat, war ja, eine formale Grammatik zu schreiben, die genau diesen Konstruktionsprozess nachvollzieht. Die also eine Maschine ist, an deren Ende jeweils ein vollständiger guter Satz des Deutschen generiert wird, deswegen generativ, generiert worden ist. Und wenn die ganze Maschine lange genug läuft, dann stellt sie alle und nur die Sätze einer Sprache her. Nicht alle, weil es rekursive Strukturen gibt. Also die Menge der Sätze, das war einer der wesentlichen Dogmen, ist unendlich, aber die Maschine kann im Prinzip jeden einzelnen herstellen und stellt nichts anderes her. Also diese Grenze zu ziehen, das war die faszinierende Idee.
Das heißt so über die Zeit quasi mit der Beschäftigung mit der Akustik und der Phonetik, die ja dann auch schon eine sehr modulare Betrachtung von Sprache ist auf einer sehr technischen Ebene und dann diese in gewisser Hinsicht gescheiterten frühen Versuch, Übersetzung oder überhaupt Sprachanalyse mit Computern zu automatisieren, sind Sie letzten Endes so auf diesen Film gekommen, jetzt will ich das Deutsch aber auch wirklich mal komplett verstehen. Mal soweit durch analysieren und soweit auch beschreiben, um vielleicht für solche Vorgänge dann in der Zukunft auch die Basis zu liefern.
Ja, also in der Zeit des Übergangs ist es genau so gewesen, wie Sie sagen. Es gab immer noch die Perspektive, diese Probleme weiter zu bearbeiten. Aber meine persönliche Entwicklung ist dann tatsächlich ganz anders verlaufen. Ich habe mich sozusagen antizyklisch bewegt, immer weiter davon weg. Bis ich dann schließlich bei der deutschen Grammatik gelandet bin.
Genau und da haben Sie ja dann auch so ein kann man sagen Standartwerk geliefert, „Grundriss der deutschen Grammatik“ in zwei Bänden, was immer noch zum Verkauf steht und wohl auch noch bezogen wird, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Wo es einfach mal alles genau beschrieben wurde.
Naja, ich war ja dann Hochschullehrer, ich war Professor und hatte die Grammatikvorlesung zu halten für Lehrerstudenten und für andere Interessierte und habe die Grammatiken alle durchprobiert und keine hat mir gefallen, ich habe sie wirklich alle ausprobiert. Und dann habe ich versucht, in meinem Kollegenkreis eine Gruppe zusammen zu kriegen, die eine deutsche Grammatik schrieben. Wir haben uns aber sofort zerstritten, weil jeder was anderes wollte und da habe ich gesagt, na gut, dann mache ich es eben alleine. Und das war natürlich ein bisschen risikoreich und habe ich viele Jahre dran gearbeitet. Das ist eine Grammatik, die man lesen kann. Also die nicht im Wesentlichen aus Tabellen besteht, sondern die man lesen kann, wie ein Buch. Die die Dinge entwickelt in Prosa, in wissenschaftlicher Prosa, mit sehr vielen Beispielen und eben mit Aufgaben. Grammatik lernt man nur, wenn man die Sprache in die Hand nimmt und sie praktisch bearbeitet. Das geht nicht über das Verstehen von Strukturen, sondern es geht um das Handhaben von Struktur. Und da kam mir das alles natürlich die formalen Grammatiken und auch die Akustik, das kam mir alles zugute dabei.
Womit wir eigentlich jetzt beim Deutschen gelandet wären, was ja auch so ein bisschen im Mittelpunkt stehen soll hier. Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zur Sprache selbst. Gut für uns ist das jetzt so das, was wir gelernt haben, was wir irgendwie mehr oder weniger gut können. Sprechen können, lesen können. Wie ist denn das Deutsche überhaupt entstanden, ohne jetzt da einen kompletten historischen Abriss einklagen zu wollen, aber die deutsche Sprache ist ja schon nochmal auch in Europa erst mal was – weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt was besonderes sagen kann – aber zumindest steht sie jetzt nicht in so einer Tradition, wie das Italienische und das Französische. Wie muss man so das Deutsche verorten?
Also eher wie das Italienische, gar nicht wie das Französische. Wenn wir die Zeit ins Auge fassen, wie man das Neuhochdeutsche nennt, dann ist der Entwicklungsprozess dessen, was wir heute als das überregionale Deutsch oder das Standarddeutsch oder das Normaldeutsch, also das Deutsch, das in der gesamten deutschen Sprachgemeinschaft, mindestens in Deutschland, verwendet werden kann. Ist auf ziemlich offensichtliche Weise entstanden. Nach der Erfindung des Buchdrucks wurde die geschriebene Sprache immer wichtiger. Es gab eine zunehmende Kommunikation zwischen den verschiedenen Sprachräumen, die man im allgemeinen Dialekte nennt oder Regionalsprachen. Dann kam die Übersetzung des Neuen Testaments von Luther. Und Luther hat nicht nur das Neue Testament übersetzt und dann im ganzen deutschen Sprachraum vertrieben, sondern er hat drei Ausgaben gemacht, wobei in der 2. und der 3. Ausgabe sehr viel eingeflossen ist, was nicht aus dem Meißner Deutsch ist, sondern aus anderen Gebieten. Das war eigentlich ein Teil der wirklich genialen Leistung von Luther, dass er sehr vieles aufgenommen hat. Das wird meistens nicht genügend berücksichtigt dabei. Und dann hatten wir hier einen Text, der sehr weite Verbreitung gefunden hat. Gleichzeitig entwickelten sich in Deutschland die Wirtschaftsräume. Wurden immer größer. Die Kanzleisprache, die Sprache des Rechts, auch die Sprache der Literatur. Diese Sprachformen des Geschriebenen begannen sich regional auszubreiten, so dass die sogenannten Schreibdialekte, so spricht man davon, immer größer wurden. Die wurden immer größer und dann wurde die Entwicklung im 17. Jahrhundert bekanntlich unterbrochen durch den 30-jährigen Krieg und durch die politischen Wirren, aber danach ging es gleich in der selben Richtung weiter. Und wir hatten dann also zu Beginn der Klassik, sagen wir mal, in der zweiten Hälfte des 18. Jahrhunderts schon einen Sprachzustand erreicht, in bestimmten Gebieten Deutschlands, der sich kaum von dem unterscheidet, was wir heute als Standarddeutsch bezeichnen. Also die fortschrittlichsten Schreiber, das waren zum Teil Literaten, aber auch Sprachwissenschaftler, der Adelung, meiner Meinung nach ein Sprachgenie, der hatte den Riecher. Der hat eine Grammatik geschrieben, auch eine deutsche Orthografie und wenn man sich die anguckt...
Wer war das?
Adelung.
Ach so hieß der Herr.
Der hieß Adelung ja. Der hat eine Grammatik geschrieben und auch eine deutsche Orthografie, die sich nur in Details von dem unterscheidet, was wir heute haben. Und das 19. Jahrhundert bestand dann im Wesentlichen darin, dass dieser erreichte Stand verbreitet wurde. Da spielt dann natürlich auch die Gründung des kleindeutschen Reiches, also des 2. deutschen Reiches, des Bismarckreiches eine große Rolle. Da wurde aktiv Sprachpolitik betrieben. Da spielte auch dann eben Konrad Duden seine sehr wichtige Rolle bei der Vereinheitlichung der Orthografie. Es wurde ja alles vereinheitlicht damals. Die Spurbreite der Eisenbahn. Es wurde die Steigungd es Gewindes vereinheitlicht, was wir heute deutsche Industrienorm nennen usw. Es musste alles vereinheitlicht werden. Und in ausdrücklicher Abgrenzung zu dem, was nicht im kleindeutschen Reich war. Das muss man immer sehen. Deswegen haben wir heute diese Probleme mit dem – oder ganz vorsichtig gesagt – wäre es anders gelaufen, wenn Österreich auch Mitglied des kleindeutschen Reichs geworden wäre, was natürlich undenkbar ist. Genauso undenkbar war es, dass die deutsche Schweiz Mitglied des kleindeutschen Reiches geworden ist. Aber Bayern immerhin. Was sie ja teilweise auch schwer bereuen. Also da ist sehr viel praktische Politik gemacht worden. Sehr viel Sprachpolitik gemacht worden. Sind Fachterminologien entwickelt worden. Zum Beispiel auch die Fußballterminologie stammt daher. Gucken Sie mal das Französische an, die sagen Penalty, ein echter Anglizismus. Wir sagen Strafstoß. Die sagen Futbol, wir sagen Fußball usw. Das sind alles damals ziemlich gut entwickelte Kernwörter des Deutschen gewesen, die man sich ausgedacht hat, entwickelt hat. Gleichzeitig mit der Einführung des Fußballs. Das war das wichtige. Es gab diesen Sport gar nicht. Sport war vom Turnvater Jahn her so was wie, individueller Sport, vielleicht in einer Gruppe, aber nicht so was wie das Mannschaftsspiel. Und das kam damals auf. Der Fußball war sofort sehr populär in Deutschland und es gab den Braunschweiger Fußballlehrer, der dieses gesamte englische Vokabular ins Deutsche übertragen hat und davon lebt es heute noch.
Das heißt es wurde sozusagen sofort eine deutsche Version davon gemacht, die komplett abgeschottet war?
Genau, und das hat er ziemlich gut gemacht. Man kann so was ja auch schräg machen, aber so was, der Franzose sagt heute noch Corner, wir sagen Ecke. Ist doch einfach toll.
Na ist das nicht das selbe Wort letztlich?
Ja, die selbe Wurzel.
Ach so Corner, also das englische Corner sozusagen einfach.
Er muss Corner sagen.
Verstehe. Ausgerechnet die Franzosen, die sind doch eigentlich sehr gut darin, sich selber sich noch eigene Worte auszudenken
Sagt man.
Sagt man, ist nicht so?
Die sagen, parking, wir sagen Parkplatz. Die sagen, weekend, wir sagen Wochenende. Nein nein, so einfach ist das nicht.
Alles gelogen. Aber nochmal kurz der Sprachstamm selber, also warum ist das Deutsche so anders als die Sprache der angrenzenden Bereiche?
Also ein Charakteristikum, es ist nicht in jeder Beziehung anders als das Polnische oder das Englische oder das Italienische. Der wesentliche Unterschied zu einigen der Nachbarsprachen besteht darin, dass die deutsche überregionale Sprache, also was wir heute Standardsprache nennen,was überall verstanden und gebraucht werden, kann...
Ist das identisch mit Hochdeutsch?
Nein, es ist nicht identisch. Ich kann dazu gleich gerne zwei Sätze sagen. Dass sich diese Sprachform, diese Supervarieté, diese Superausprägung des Deutschen von unten entwickelt hat. Also die hat sich entwickelt im Gebrauch. Sie hat sich deshalb entwickelt, weil ein Bedarf daran bestand, in größeren Räumen, innerhalb des deutschen Sprachgebiets zu kommunizieren. Vor allen Dingen im Geschriebenen. Die Wirtschaftsräume wurden immer größer und die Kulturräume wurden immer größer, aber die Kleinstaaterei blieb. Das heißt wir hatten eigentlich im Prinzip schon eine überregionale Sprache, bevor wir eine deutsche Nation hatten. Das ist der wesentliche Unterschied zum Französischen. Im Französischen wurde der Staat stark gemacht und der oktroyiert eine Minderheitensprache, oktroyiert muss man vielleicht mit Vorsichtig gebrauchen, er machte eine Minderheitensprache, die vielleicht von 15% der Franzosen gesprochen wurde. Also das Französisch der Île de France machte er zur Staatssprache und hat auf diese Weise im Lauf der Zeit die Regionalsprachen, die sehr stark waren im Französischen, nicht nur das baskische und das bretonische, sondern auch so andere romanische Sprachen, wie das Katalanische, das Okzitanische, das Provinzalische usw. Die wurden marginalisiert. Das heißt in Frankreich ist die Entwicklung von oben nach unten gelaufen. In Deutschland von unten nach oben. Das ist der wesentliche Unterschied und das macht die deutsche Standardsprache auch so stark. Sie ist sehr gut verankert in der Sprachgemeinschaft. Und um die französische Sprache muss permanent gekämpft werden. Es muss permanent gekämpft werden, weil sie auch durch dieses Oktroi von oben sich nicht entwickeln kann. Sie wurde festgeschrieben. Die Entwicklung ist sehr kompliziert und sehr langsam. Bevor Sie da irgendwas durch kriegen, hat auch sein gutes, kommt niemand auf die Idee so eine dumm geradezu Orthografiereform zu machen, wie in Deutschland. Das ist in Frankreich völlig undenkbar. Das hat auch sein gutes, aber auf der anderen Seite ist die französische Sprache sehr sehr konservativ im Vergleich zum Standarddeutschen.
Worin drückt sich so eine Konservativität aus?
Das drückt sich zum Beispiel darin aus, dass im Französischen der Unterschied zwischen der geschriebenen Sprache und der gesprochenen Sprache riesig ist. Also mal ein Beispiel in einer großen französischen Grammatik, der von Gravis, steht der schöne Satz, das Substantiv des gesprochenen Französisch hat keinen Plural. Müssen Sie sich mal vorstellen. Das Substantiv des gesprochenen Französischen hat keinen Plural. Das heißt den Plural, der wird normalerweise auf s gebildet, bis auf die wenigen Ausnahmen, den hören Sie nicht, Sie sehen ihn nur.
Er ist nur in der Sprache sozusagen verwirklicht.
Er ist nur im Geschriebenen.
Nur in der geschriebenen Sprache.
Im Deutschen sind sie auf einen Artikel angewiesen oder auf irgendwas anderes.
Da ändert sich so einiges.
Und das können sie jetzt verallgemeinern. Es gibt in der französischen Sprache. Ich gebe mal das Beispiel so was wie "guarder", das ist eine ganz einfache phonetische Form G A R D E, die hat sieben Schreibungen. Mit ER, EZ, É, EE, ES usw. Und die sind alle grammatisch verschieden. Und kein Mensch hört was, er sieht es nur. Das heißt die Kinder lernen es auch erst, wenn sie schreiben lernen. Und wenn sie es nicht lernen, ist es keine Frage der Orthografie, sondern der Grammatik. Wenn sie es nicht mehr lernen, ist die Grammatik weg. Also das sind jetzt nur so kleine Beispiele. Der Unterschied im Französischen, das weiß jeder, der französisch lernt, auch in der Syntax. Nicht nur die umständlichen Höflichkeitsformeln. Das geht bis dahin in Briefen ist ja gigantisch, was man da im Französischen so macht. Der Unterschied ist riesig. Und im Deutschen ist er gnädig.
Ja das ist eine interessante Betrachtungsweise. Das heißt im Deutschen ist eigentlich die Sprache insofern sehr ehrlich, als dass eben das Gesprochene und das Geschriebene doch sehr nah beieinander ist.
Ja, also ehrlich... es ist so.
Vielleicht sollte man es nicht werten, aber man kann es feststellen, dass das gesprochene Wort und das geschriebene Wort …
Man kann schon soweit gehen, dass man sagen kann, im Französischen gibt es Probleme in der Sprachvermittlung, die es in dieser Form im Deutschen nicht gibt. Wir haben auch Probleme bei der Vermittlung der Orthografie, aber das sind dann nicht von vorne bis hinten grammatische Probleme gleich.
Das Englische hat ja auch nicht unbedingt immer so viel das ... also das gesprochene Englisch hat auch nicht unbedingt immer sehr viel zu tun mit dem geschriebenen Englisch.
Ja ganz richtig. Im Englischen ist die Sache insofern anders, als dass das Englische sehr früh und sehr intensiv den Einfluss des Französischen zu spüren bekommen hat. Nach der Schlacht bei Hastings ist ja die französische Oberschicht aus der Normandie nach England eingewandert und konnte nicht mehr zurück aus politischen Gründen. Hat sich dort festgesetzt und hat das ganze fremde Vokabular ins Englische transportiert. Und das was wir im Deutschen so schön haben, diese Trennung von Kernwortschatz und Fremdwortschatz, den haben wir im Englischen nicht. Im Englischen haben sich diese germanischen Sprachteile und die romanischen Sprachteile sehr früh miteinander vermischt und das sieht man auch an der Grammatik. Das kann man im Einzelnen zeigen. Also da ist die Situation wieder völlig anders. Im Englischen ist es auch so, dass die Normierung der Sprache völlig anders geregelt wird als im Deutschen und im Französischen. Dort gibt es ebenso wie überall im Englischen Kasuistik, da kommt es auf den Einzelfall an. Und deswegen hat den allergrößten Einfluss im Englischen das Oxford English Dictionary. Die haben auch sehr viel Ressourcen, die sind sehr reich. Und wer es wissen will, wie es richtig ist, der guckt da rein. Das steht da alles drin. Aber warum es so und nicht anders ist, das ist eine schwierige Frage, die kann man in Bezug auf das Deutsche im Allgemeinen leichter beantworten als im Englischen.
Aber spielt hier nicht der Duden dann eine entsprechende Rolle?
Der Duden? Naja es kommt darauf an, was man unter dem Duden versteht. Der Rechtschreibduden?
Ja der Rechtschreibduden.
Der spielt eine große Rolle im Deutschen, aber das OED ist kein Rechtschreibwörterbuch. Das ist ein Universalwörterbuch, in dem sehr viel über Grammatik drin steht, über Gebrauch, Belege usw. Während ja der Vorteil des Duden ist, da steht auch ein bisschen drin. Der erste Duden, den Konrad Duden gemacht hat 1880, war eine reine Wörterliste. Und der Duden hat sich auch so ein bisschen zum Wörterbuch entwickelt, in dem andere Sachen drin stehen, aber ganz wenig. Das kann man mit dem englischen Wörterbuch nicht vergleichen.
Das heißt im Deutschen, ich meine man könnte jetzt noch die anderen Sprachfamilien drum herum auch noch abklappern, würde vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit führen, wenn wir jetzt noch so die skandinavischen und slavischen Sachen in Bezug nehmen. Ich denke, ich habe schon so ein bisschen verstanden, was so das Deutsche an der Stelle auch so eigen macht. Ist ja überhaupt interessant zu sehen, dass es ja jetzt rein quantitativ auch die meistgesprochene Sprache in Europa ist, wenn ich da nicht irgendwas übersehen habe.
Ja das sehen Sie vollkommen richtig.
Also viele Leute benutzen das, weil einfach viele Leute in Deutschland, Österreich und in der Schweiz leben, plus noch so ein paar Regionen, wo das auch noch Verwendung findet. Was sagt denn das jetzt über die Bedeutung und Stellung des Deutschen so zu den anderen weitverbreiteten Sprachen aus?
Naja also um diese Frage zu beantworten, muss man sich auf ein paar Aspekte verständigen, unter denen man das betrachtet. Ich sage Ihnen mal einfach ein paar Zahlen. Es gibt 6.000 Sprachen auf der Erde. Und hoffentlich sage ich jetzt nicht was ungenaues, von denen sind – so viel ich mich erinnere – in der Größenordnung von 800 verschriftet.
Also die überhaupt eine Schriftform haben.
Ja. Und etwa in der selben Größenordnung, etwas weniger an Sprachen, haben so was, wie die Übersetzung der Bibel. Das heißt da ist das Geschriebene so weit, dass man auch komplexe Texte übersetzen kann. Und wenn man diese Hierarchie weiter runter betet, dann kommt man auf so was wie, es gibt 100 Sprachen ungefähr oder 120, die sind Staatssprachen, mehr sind das nicht.
Also die als offizielle Sprache eines Landes geführt werden.
So ist es. Und es gibt – das kann sich jetzt auch wieder geändert haben – ungefähr 80 Sprachen, die eine eigene Software haben in ihrer Sprache.
Eine eigene Software?
Ja, also dass Sie eine Computerterminologie haben, die auch in der Software verwendet werden kann. Das können Sie im Deutschen ja machen, das heißt nicht, dass es überall gemacht wird. Aber Sie können das ja machen.
Also so was wie Programm oder so was?
So ist es. Die Computerterminologie ist viel weniger Englisch, also anglizistisch als man im Allgemeinen annimmt übrigens. Aber gut, wir sind jetzt nicht bei den Fremdwörtern. Man sagt, dass ungefähr 30 Sprachen soweit ausgebaut sind, dass sie alles haben, was man sich vorstellen kann. Dass sie geschrieben sind, gesprochen sind, dass sie einen überregionalen Standard haben, dass sie eine Literatursprache haben, die entsprechend elaboriert ist und eine Wissenschaftssprache, dass sie Dialekte haben und dass sie technische Vokabularien haben, also Fachsprachen usw. Und zu diesen Sprachen gehört auf jeden Fall das Deutsche.
30 Sprachen, die als Wissenschaftssprache dadurch überhaupt erst taugen, weil sie so vollumfänglich definiert sind.
So ist es. Ohne jetzt mal viel zu riskieren. Gucken Sie mal das Arabische an zum Beispiel. Eine der ganz großen Sprachen der Erde, mit einer ganz großen Wissenschaftstradition. Ohne das Arabische hätten wir die ganze antike Wissenschaft nicht rüber gekriegt ins sogenannten Abendland.
Oder Zahlen.
Heute gibt es große Probleme im Arabischen. Das Arabische ohne Risiko als Wissenschaftssprache zu verwenden. Also ich war länger in Ägypten, habe dort gearbeitet an der Al-Azhar-Universität, an der Deutschabteilung und haben das dort kennengelernt. Es ist nicht so, dass Sie mit der arabischen Sprache alles machen dürfen.
Was heißt das?
Dass Sie Schwierigkeiten kriegen, wenn Sie auf bestimmten Gebieten anfangen, eine Fachterminologie zu entwickeln und zu verwenden.
Mit wem kriegt man da Schwierigkeiten?
Na mit wem wohl. Sie kriegen politische Schwierigkeiten? Das ist so. Und das heißt nicht, dass da nichts passiert. Es gibt sehr starke Entwicklungen, aber in einigen arabischen Ländern führt es dazu, dass wenn Wissenschaft gemacht wird, dann lieber gleich auf englisch. Oder nehmen Sie das Russische. Solange es die Sowjetunion gab, war das ganz klar das Ideologen, wir machen unsere eigene Wissenschaftssprache. Und das führt heute dazu, dass es eine Spaltung gibt in Russland. Auf der einen Seite sind die Modernisierer, die das Englische benutzen wollen, weil sie sagen, wir müssen es. Auf der anderen Seite sind da die traditionellen Strukturen, das kann man ja auch immer wieder in der Zeitung so lesen, die sagen, machen wir nicht, wollen wir nicht. Das sind Schwierigkeiten völlig anderer Art und das Russische ist natürlich eine Universalsprache, ganz klar. Aber es gibt große Schwierigkeiten verschiedener Art im heutigen Russland. Also da kann man über einzelne Sprachen sehr interessante Dinge sagen, aber die Sprachen, die mit einer so langen Tradition, wie das Deutsche, ihre Wissenschaftsterminologien, Syntaxen usw. entwickeln konnten, so dass sie ohne wenn und aber für die Wissenschaft zur Verfügung stehen, die sind nicht so zahlreich wie man denken sollte.
Sind das jetzt nur die 30, die Sie erwähnt haben?
Ja.
Also das ist quasi die Gruppe der Universalsprachen. Universalsprache heißt, hat irgendwie alles, hat auch eine eigene Wissenschaftssprache. Das Persische zählt dann auch dazu?
Das Persische zählt dazu.
Aber das Arabische nur eingeschränkt.
Also da will ich jetzt mal nicht so ein einfaches Statement abgeben. Darüber müsste man …
... ein längeres Paper schreiben.
... im einzelnen reden. Aber offensichtlich ist es nicht. Im Deutschen ist es offensichtlich.
Gut, aber so oder so, das Deutsche ist ganz klar in diesem Bereich. Ist eine der ungefähr 30 Universalsprachen.
Und das sind 30 von 6.000, da bewegen Sie sich im Promillbereich. Man sollte sich diese Verhältnisse vor Augen führen, bevor man anfängt, auf das Deutsche zu schimpfen. Das Deutsche befindet sich in einem prinzipiell guten Zustand, den nur wenige Sprachen in dieser Weise haben. Französisch ist eine Universalsprache. Ich habe Ihnen aber mal vorhin ein Problem genannt, das das Französische hat. Dass das Deutsche so nicht hat. Die starke …
Schrift und gesprochene Sprache.
Also da drückt es sich aus.
Aber das heißt ja im Prinzip, das Deutsche steht jetzt primär erst mal so auch in einem Wettbewerb mit den anderen Universalsprachen, wenn es darum geht, für wissenschaftliche Tätigkeit jetzt auch „die richtige“ Sprache zu wählen.
Naja also das Deutsche steht in Konkurrenz auf jeden Fall, wenn man seine internationale Verwendung ansieht und es steht – aber das ist gelaufen, das Deutsche spielt als Wissenschaftssprache international nur noch eine sehr marginale Rolle, es gibt noch ein paar kleine Disziplinen aus der Vor- und Frühgeschichte zum Beispiel, wo das Deutsche noch immer international die Kommunikationssprache ist. Aber im Allgemeinen ist es das nicht. Wenn man von Konkurrenz spricht, dann muss man nach innen gucken und sagen, deutsch steht im deutschen Sprachgebiet in Konkurrenz zum Englischen. Das ist – und zwar nur zum Englischen – das ist aber auch eine Situation, in der sich mehr oder weniger vergleichbare Sprachen auch befinden. Ich würde soweit gehen, also gucken Sie mal das Niederländische an, 20 Millionen Sprecher ungefähr, eine mittelgroße Sprache, da kann jeder Englisch, besser als bei uns. Und die ganze Wissenschaft wird auf Englisch abgewickelt, nicht die ganze, sondern ein sehr sehr großer Teil, viel größer als bei uns.
Auch in Skandinavien ähnlicher Fall oder?
Ja, obwohl es Gegenbewegungen gibt gerade in Schweden. Und zum Dänischen kann man auch interessante Dinge reden. Also ich habe Freunde in Dänemark, die mir sagen, obwohl mal in Dänemark die Diskussion so geführt wurde, als solle man das Englische als zweite Amtssprache einführen sogar. Da wird mir gesagt, dass in den meisten Disziplinen in Dänemark, innerhalb der Labors weitgehend Dänisch gesprochen wird. Wenn nicht gerade ein amerikanischer Kollege da ist oder mehrere, die nichts verstehen. Aber wenn sie nichts verstehen sollen, natürlich. Aber auch im Alltag wird sehr viel mehr dänisch gesprochen, als man an den schriftlichen Äußerungen erkennen kann. Was das bedeutet für die Sprache, ist nicht gut erforscht. Also wie viel Vokabular die da wirklich auf dänisch haben, Wissenschaftsvokabular, ist nicht gut erforscht. Das ist nur mal so eine interessante These, wie das genau im Deutschen ist wissen wir nicht, aber wir wissen, dass das Deutsche immer noch universell verwendbar ist. Das heißt wenn wir wollen, können wir eine Terminologie, wie bestimmten naturwissenschaftlichen Teildisziplinen oder auch Ökonomie nur in Englisch gibt, wir können sie sofort auf deutsch herstellen, wir haben die Mittel, das ist gar keine Frage. Wir haben die Mittel und deswegen ist für mich immer in dem Zusammenhang die Frage, sollen wir nicht uns überlegen, wie wir das Deutsche innerhalb des deutschen Sprachgebiets so stärken können, dass diese Mittel auch tatsächlich angewandt werden. Und meine These ist, das vernünftigste wäre, um das Deutsche als Wissenschaftssprache intern zu pflegen, das Grundstudium und das Studium bis zum Vordiplom und den ersten Bachelor und so weiter obligatorisch auf deutsch abzuhalten. Dann wäre jeder Professor, jeder Physiker und jeder Chemiker und jeder Soziologe gezwungen, den Studenten der ersten Semester seine Disziplin auch mit deutschem Vokabular nahezubringen.
Geht es um das Vokabular oder um die komplette Durchführung des Studiums?
Nein, es geht nur um die erste Studienphase, aber da wird deutsch komplett verwendet. Also die Vorlesung „Einführung in die Physik“ oder „Einführung in die Experimentalphysik“ oder irgend so etwas, die wird auf deutsch abgehalten. Das ist denke ich das probateste Mittel, um zu verhindern, dass es bestimmte Bereiche von wissenschaftlichen Terminologien, die noch zum Allgemeinen gehören, dass es die absehbar nicht mehr geben wird.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, will man das überhaupt? Muss man das jetzt überhaupt machen? Ich meine wir haben jetzt so eine internationale Entwicklung. Ich meine 30 Universalsprachen, ich denke, es ist absehbar, dass da noch ein paar von schwächeln werden so in den nächsten paar hundert Jahren, dass sich, ich weiß nicht, wie Sie das so sehen, aber wenn ich jetzt so Bladrunner gucke, dann reden alle nur noch irgendwie so eine Melange aus Englisch und Chinesisch. Das ist so die Vision der Science Fiction an der Stelle, die ja linguistisch auch schon mal bei 2001 Einzug gehalten hat. So dass eigentlich im zunehmenden Maße so eine Globalisierung stattfindet, auch ausgelöst natürlich durch die Globalisierung der Kommunikation und in gewisser Hinsicht auch der Internationalisierung dieser Wissenschaft, die einfach nicht mehr lokal stattfindet. Ist das Englische an der Stelle jetzt schon unvermeidlich, ist der Zug da schon abgefahren, muss man sich überhaupt Gedanken über so eine Diskussion machen?
Naja also vor der Hand ist der Zug abgefahren. Ob er auf die Dauer abgefahren ist, das entscheidet sich nicht am Verhältnis von englisch und deutsch, sondern das entscheidet sich vielleicht mal, da gibt es Spekulationen, am Verhältnis von englisch und chinesisch. Darauf nehme ich nicht Bezug. Ich bin auch nicht der Meinung, dass man das Englische bekämpfen muss, gar nicht. Das ist absolut weltfremd. Für mich steht eher mit einer großen Zahl der Kollegen die Frage, ob wir es uns erlauben können, alle noch vorhandenen ausgebauten Sprachen in bestimmten Verwendungsdomänen aufzugeben, so dass wir nachher tatsächlich vielleicht nur noch das Englische und das Chinesische und das Russische und das Spanische haben. Und da ist die Antwort ganz klar, nein. Wir sollen es nicht aufgeben. Sondern erstens wissen wir nicht was passiert global. Ich war auch lange in Georgien, ich erzähle Ihnen mal einen Schwank aus meinem Leben. In Georgien war russisch verpflichtend in der Wissenschaft. Dissertationen wurden auf russisch geschrieben. Aber in der georgianischen Teilrepublik war es auch Pflicht in den meisten Fächern eine georgische Version einzureichen. Das hat dazu geführt, dass nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion, georgisch als Wissenschaftssprache sofort zur Verfügung stand. Was in Aserbaidschan zum Beispiel dem Nachbarland nicht der Fall war. Und das meine ich. Wir wissen nicht, was in den nächsten 100 Jahren passiert und wir können uns ohne weiteres Szenarien vorstellen, in denen wir froh sind, wenn wir das Deutsche haben. Das ist aber so ein bisschen Spekulation und man weiß ja nie, und man soll auch das nicht aufgeben, was man hat. Es gibt ganz andere Gesichtspunkte in diesem Zusammenhang. Einer ist das berühmte, geht von dem berühmten humboldtschen Diktum aus, das habe ich da auch zur Geltung bringen wollen, dass die Sprachform, die Struktur des Vokabulars mit ausschlaggebend sind für die Denkform. Und das würde bedeuten, dass Sie in bestimmten Disziplinen zumindest eine Denkform aufgeben, wenn Sie das Deutsche aufgeben. Es wird zum Beispiel, um mal was ganz traditionelles zu sagen, die These vertreten, dass Sigmund Freud seine Werke in französisch gar nicht so hätte schreiben können, wie er es gemacht hat.
Jetzt mal als Behauptung?
Mal als Behauptung. Nur damit klar ist, was hier vertreten wird. In den Geisteswissenschaften ist das auch wahrscheinlich so, da gibt es ja auch sehr wenig englisch noch. Gibt es auch, aber relativ wenig. Und wie weit das für die Naturwissenschaften gilt, das ist genau eine der interessanten Fragen. Aber es gibt eben in den Naturwissenschaften auch zunehmend Wissenschaftler, prominente Wissenschaftler, die sagen, wir sind froh, wenn wir noch die Möglichkeit haben, mit Alltagsbegriffen in unserer Disziplin zu operieren. Ich habe ja einen Chemiker zitiert, der das gesagt hat, mit den komplexen Terminologien, die sozusagen Realdefinitionen sind, so wie Polihexanid Tetrafluorethylen und so was, wo Sie dem Wort ansehen, was da drin steckt, kommen wir in bestimmten Zusammenhängen in der Chemie nicht mehr zurecht, die sind einfach zu kompliziert. Da müssen wir was anderes machen. Das machen wir auch. Und das was wir machen, knüpft an die Alltagssprache an. Und da ist das Deutsche traditionell sehr stark. Das Deutsche hat diese einfachen – also schon im 18. Jahrhundert. Philosophie, Geistwissenschaft oder Verstandeswissenschaft, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr - da wurden solche Verdeutschungen gemacht, die sprechend waren, im Gegensatz zu den Latinismen oder Graezismen. Da ist das Deutsche sehr stark.
Können Sie mir mal ein Beispiel nennen, weil das kann ich mir jetzt gerade nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Naja so was wie Philosophie oder Ontologie oder damals wurde die ganze Philosophie verdeutscht. Philosophie ist irgendwie so was wie Geistwissenschaft oder so was. Und das wurde von dem Philosophen Wolf mit großer Verve und sehr weit durchgeführt und das hat eben gezeigt, dass wir die Mittel haben, wenn wir wollen, diese Begriffe im deutschen Kernwortschatz zu verankern. Ich bin gar nicht dafür, dass das da gemacht wird. Ich bin aber auf jeden Fall dafür, dass diese Mittel erhalten bleiben, dass die deutsche Wortbildung lebendig bleibt und auch verwendet wird im Wissenschaftsbereich. Das dritte, was man in diesem Zusammenhang unbedingt sehen muss und was nicht gesehen wird, zu wenig gesehen wird, das ist, dass sich das Verhältnis der Wissenschaft zur Öffentlichkeit ändert. Die Wissenschaftssprache, als ich ein junger Wissenschaftler wurde, hatte Anforderungen – damals war deutsch in vielen Gebieten unbestritten auch in der E-Technik, da kam niemand auf die Idee irgendwie eine englische Vorlesung zu halten – da gab es so Anforderungen an die Wissenschaftssprache. Das Subjekt bleibt draußen, das wird alles in ruhigem, objektivem Tonus formuliert und wie verständlich das ist nach außen, das ist nicht so wichtig. Das hat sich alles geändert. Was wollen Sie eigentlich unter Wissenschaftssprache verstehen. Denken Sie mal an den Diskurs, der geführt wurde und geführt wird über Gentechnik. Was wollen Sie denn eigentlich... also wir sind heute darauf angewiesen, dass die Öffentlichkeit stärker als früher den Gang der Wissenschaft akzeptiert und begleitet. Das geht manchmal sogar zu weit, meiner Meinung nach, dass also zu viel Öffentlichkeitsarbeit gemacht wird. Und der Öffentlichkeit das Blaue vom Himmel herunter erzählt wird. Das gibt es auch. Es geht ja ums Geld. Letzten Endes geht es ums Geld. Und mal abgesehen von den Probleme, die es überall gibt, die es ja auch gibt, aber ist es doch ganz offensichtlich, dass eine Disziplin, die überhaupt keine Wörter mehr hat und überhaupt nicht mehr gewohnt ist, sich auf deutsch zur Sache zu äußern, hier auf die Dauer ein unüberwindbares Problem bekommt. Und all diese Dinge vermeidet man, wenn man mit begründeten Ausnahmen, natürlich müssen möglich sein in bestimmten speziellen Fällen muss das Englische von Vornherein zugelassen sein. Im graduierten Bereich sowieso. Wenn die Wissenschaftler nach Deutsch(Land) zum studieren kommen, die Freshmen, die Erstsemester wollen die Deutsch zum großen Teil. Die sind schwer enttäuscht, wenn sie hier her kommen aus Polen oder auch aus Frankreich. Ich habe es erlebt wirklich mehrfach.
Also wenn sie in Deutschland studieren.
Wenn sie in Deutschland studieren und es wird ihnen alles auf Englisch um die Ohren geknallt. Das wollen die nicht. Und dazu kommen die hier nicht her. Und da sollen wir ein bisschen Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln und unsere schöne wunderbare Wissenschaftssprache auch selbstbewusst verwenden. Nun weiß ich schon, da gibt es alle möglichen Einwände. Das bezieht sich wirklich nur auf die erste Studienphase. Und es kostet fast nichts. Und es wird auch dieser permanenten Angeberei, dass man da rumläuft mit seinem basic simple english und die Leute beeindruckt. Und ich war jahrelang gewählter Fachgutachter bei der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft und habe diese Anträge gesehen, von den hochprätenziösen Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die kein Englisch können und einem da irgend so einen Antrag um die Ohren gehauen haben. Dass wir ihnen zurück gegeben haben und gesagt haben, mach das mal auf deutsch, das ist wirklich besser. Also das diese permanente Nachricht, ich bin globalisiert, ich bin weltläufig, die ja auch in der Ökonomie eine große Rolle spielt, dass die zumindest in der Wissenschaft so klein gehalten wird, wie es irgend geht, diese Angeberei.
Ich will nochmal auf einen anderen Aspekt auf diese Frage eingehen. Ich verstehe schon, das hat auch ein bisschen was mit einer eigenen Wissenschaftskultur zu tun, dass man vor allem den Studieneinstieg im Wesentlichen in der eigenen Sprache macht. Wenn ich jetzt mir aber vorstelle, ich mein jetzt ein Wissenschaftler, der auch Ergebnisse erzielt, sprich Papers schreibt, Papiere. Wie sagt man denn eigentlich auf deutsch? Und ich muss das jetzt eben in einer mir fremden Sprache bzw. In einer Sprache, die nicht meine Muttersprache ist formulieren. Geht da was verloren? Was verloren für den wissenschaftlichen Prozess? Geht da was verloren in der Qualität, in der ich mich ausdrücken kann? Geht anderen damit was verloren? Wäre ich nicht besser dran, wenn ich mein Paper – wie sagt man denn jetzt auf deutsch?
Einen Aufsatz.
Einen Aufsatz, wenn ich den in der Muttersprache schreiben würde, wäre das nicht für alle Beteiligten besser?
Eben nicht für alle. Also das hängt jetzt wieder von den Bedingungen ab, unter denen ein junger Wissenschaftler arbeitet. Rebus sic stantibus. Also so wie die Dinge nun mal liegen heutzutage, ist es so, dass er im Interesse seiner eigenen Karriere versucht, auf Englisch zu publizieren. Das muss er lernen. Das geht nicht von heute auf morgen. Aber der erste Erwerb und die erste Verfassung von Seminararbeiten sagen wir mal oder von Berichten über Laborübungen, die machen sich auf jeden Fall für einen deutschen Muttersprachler leichter auf deutsch. Die Wissenschaft kommt auf ihn zu in seiner eigenen Sprache. Das ist so. Und wenn er sie versteht, wenn er in ihr heimisch wird, dann wird er selbst auch sehr viel größeren Wert darauf legen können, dass er in der Fremdsprache, wenn er sie dann einigermaßen beherrscht, auch soweit es irgend möglich ist, das sagt, was er sagen will. Was er eben auch in seiner Muttersprache zu sagen gelernt hat. Also ich habe mich auch – ja gut, das ist eigentlich das Wesentliche – für ihn persönlich geht es heute darum, dass er in bestimmten Disziplinen international sichtbar wird. Da gibt es diese Indizes und alles mögliche komische Zeug, dem sich die jungen Wissenschaftler beugen müssen. Dagegen kann man sehr viel reden, das tue ich aber nicht in diesem Zusammenhang, das ist nicht mein Thema. Mein Thema ist, dass ihm seine Disziplin zunächst mal in der Denkform nahegebracht wird, in der er sozialisiert ist. Die sozusagen das ganz eigene ist. Und wenn er sich dann international betätigt, dann muss er das mit den anderen auf Augenhöhe können und da müssen wir sehr viel für die Verbesserung des Englischen in verschiedenen Disziplinen in Deutschland tun. Das ist gar keine Frage. Wenn wir unsere Leute konkurrenzfähig halten wollen. Wir haben da weniger Probleme zum Beispiel als die Franzosen, die haben da sehr viel mehr Probleme aus bestimmten Gründen. Aber wir haben mehr Probleme als die Schweden oder die Holländer. Ich rede nicht dem Provinzialismus das Wort, überhaupt nicht! Und wenn die Graduiertenschulen auf Englisch angelegt werden, ist in den meisten Fällen nichts gegen zu sagen. Und wenn englische Textbücher verwendet werden oder amerikanische. Also Textbücher in englischer Sprache. Traumhaft wäre es natürlich auch, es würde mal ein französisches vorkommen. Aber wenn die verwendet werden schon von Anfang an, ist nichts gegen zu sagen, gar nichts. Aber dass unsere Studenten generell, so wie es absehbar an der TU München gemacht werden soll, nur noch englisch hören in ihren Studien, das halte ich für kontraproduktiv, was die Sache betrifft. Und nicht nur, weil ich einer bin, dem die deutsche Sprache am Herzen liegt, sondern auch, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass die Studierenden so beweglich sein müssen, dass sie das nicht nur in einer ihnen fremden Sprache sagen können, was sie sagen wollen, sondern es immer wieder auch sich fragen können, wie ist denn das im Deutschen? Was steckt denn da dahinter? Wie könnte ich denn das sagen? Also ich sage Ihnen mal ein Beispiel aus einem anderen Bereich. Ich habe kürzlich beim deutschen Übersetzerfond einen Vortrag gehalten über literarische Übersetzungen, aus dem Englischen ins Deutsche. Und habe das an einem berühmten Fall gemacht, am Roman von Williams, der heißt „Stoner“. Das ist die Geschichte eines amerikanischen Literaturwissenschaftlers an der Uni. Und das ist ein wunderbares amerikanisches Englisch. Ganz wunderbar. Ich habe mir die deutsche Übersetzung angeguckt, die auch sehr professionell ist und sehr gut. Und habe, um das mal ganz konkret zu sagen, festgestellt, dass nur ein Drittel der englischen amerikanischen Passive im Deutschen als Passiv wiedergegeben wird. Zwei Drittel nicht. Sondern wenn da steht „er wird geschlagen“ „he has beaten“ oder so was, gut in einem Drittel funktioniert es, in zwei Dritteln der Fälle funktioniert es nicht. Und als ich das da vorgetragen habe, da haben die Übersetzer nur gestaunt. Und haben gesagt, kannst du uns auch erklären, warum? Habe ich gesagt, ja kann ich. Das liegt an der Grammatik des englischen Passivs. Stellen Sie sich mal vor, da steht so ein Satz wie, „he was married“ so und so und so und so. Der Protagonist Stoner und im Deutschen heißt es dann, „er wurde verheiratet“. Stellen Sie sich das mal vor. Das ist was völlig anderes. Und es liegt daran, dass das Passiv in der englischen Grammatik einen vollkommen anderen Status hat als das Passiv in der deutschen. Das müsste man jetzt im einzelnen ausfalten, kann man machen, aber was dann die deutsche Übersetzung bringt tatsächlich, das ist dem, was im amerikanischen Passiv drinsteht, mehr oder weniger nah. Mehr oder weniger. Da wird gesucht. Umgekehrt ist es genauso. Ich habe dann auch geguckt, wie sieht das in englischen Übersetzungen aus von deutschen literarischen Texten. Die müssen Klimmzüge machen teilweise, einfach weil sie die Konstruktionen nicht abbilden können, die das Deutsche locker verwendet. So was wie vorausgestelltes Attribut. Das jedem Kind bekömmliche Vollkornbrot. Jedem Kind bekömmlich. Das müssen Sie mal auf englisch sagen, da kommt sonst was raus.
Ja genau, da denke ich auch schon die ganze Zeit drüber nach, auch so aus meiner eigenen Erfahrung mit Deutsch und Englisch, wenn ich versuche, Dinge bestimmte Dinge, die mir aus dem englischen Kulturraum oder aus dem amerikanischen, also aus dem Anglokulturraum, mir bekannt sind, ins Deutsche zu übertragen, scheitere ich manchmal bei der Wortwahl. Genauso habe ich Probleme, mir eben aus dem deutschen Kulturraum bekannte Phänomene englischen Sprechern entgegenzubringen, das ist einfach sehr schwierig. Was ich daraus für mich ableite, ist, Sprache formt das Denken. Die Art und Weise, wie ich im Deutschen meine Gedanken modelliere funktionieren irgendwie anders, als wenn ich das mit Englisch mache. Und ich habe auch so meine Domänen, wo ich die andere Sprache bevorzuge. Ich bin groß geworden mit der Computerwelt und die war für mich von Anfang an irgendwie englisch. Ich kann so mit Direktzugriffspeicher und so was irgendwie nichts anfangen. Das bringt mich nicht weiter. Das ist mir dann auch interessanterweise meiner eigenen Sprache dann auch schon wieder zu nahe. Also ich benutze es explizit im Englischen als Fremdbegriff, der für mich automatisch ein Fachbegriff ist und manchmal bin ich auch total überrascht, wenn ich so im normalen Umgang mit – ja im normalen, ich bin im Ausland, ich bin in England, rede mit Leuten und dann benutzen die auf einmal für ganz normale Dinge Wörter, die für mich einfach als Fachbegriff abgestempelt. Und dann denke ich so, das kann man auch außerhalb dieses Computerkontextes benutzen, ist ja lustig. Und dann merke ich erst, ahja da kommt das irgendwie her. Also worauf ich hinaus will ist, Sprache formt das Denken und vielleicht ist ja – das ist nur eine von mir in den Raum gestellte These – vielleicht liegt ja eine eigene Qualität darin, sich mit dem Deutschen mit etwas auseinanderzusetzen versus des Einsatzes einer populäreren Sprache, ist das was dran oder rede ich jetzt dummes Zeug?
Nein, da ist was dran. Sie haben das jetzt auf die Wörter bezogen. Das ist ja auch gut.
Wörter oder eben auch diese Konstellation, wie rum beschreibe ich das, wer ist jetzt der aktive, der passive Teil und deswegen kam mir das jetzt gerade auch in den Sinn.
Also es gibt, was ich eben sagen wollte war eigentlich, es geht bis tief in die Grammatik. Und es gibt zum Beispiel Untersuchungen. Das wir jetzt alles erst so richtig aufgerollt in der letzten Zeit. Es gibt zum Beispiel Untersuchungen, die zeigen, dass wenn das Englische – egal ob literarische Sprache oder Wissenschaftssprache – Satzgefüge baut, die ungefähr so komplex sind, wie sie im Deutschen ganz normal sind, dann sind sie schwer verständlich, während sie im Deutschen noch sehr gut verständlich sind. Das liegt einfach daran, wie das Deutsche die Unterordnung und die Nebenordnung von Nebensätzen und Hauptsätzen regelt. Viel höher strukturiert als das Englische. Das Englische gilt ja auch als Sprache, die so gut lesbar ist. Englische Lehrbücher zum Beispiel. Das liegt daran, dass sie unter anderem kürzere Sätze verwenden. Aber wenn diese kürzeren Sätze auf der Zerhackung eines langen deutschen Satzes beruhen, dann kommt etwas ganz anderes dabei raus. Das was Sie jetzt zum Teil für Wörter expliziert haben, was ja auch in bestimmten Bereichen sehr gut untersucht ist, wo das Englische mit auch sogar deutsche Fremdwörter verwendet, ist ja gut bekannt, das geht bis tief in die Grammatik hinein. Die Frage, die wir, wenn wir über Wissenschaftssprache reden, aber stellen müssen, ist, wie weit geht sie in die Wissenschaft rein. Das ist nicht so trivial. Also wie gesagt, in den Geisteswissenschaften in der Literatur ist das gar keine Frage, auch im Zeitungsdeutsch ist das gar keine Frage, im Allgemeindeutsch, aber wie weit das in die Naturwissenschaften reingeht, wie weit der deutsche Physiker, der wirklich gut auf Deutsch sozialisiert ist, anders denkt als der britische oder der amerikanische oder der russische, das ist ein Thema, in dem es mehr Behauptungen gibt als Wissen bisher. Aber eine letzten Endes nicht beantwortete Frage. Deswegen komme ich, wenn ich darauf spreche, dass wir an den Universitäten im Grundstudium deutsch sprechen sollen, darauf auch nur am Rande zu sprechen. Es gibt genügend praktische Gründe, die dafür sprechen, dass wir das tun. Aber die Aussicht, dass das angefasst wird, von unserer Kultusministerkonferenz, Direktorenkonferenz ist da anders. Direktorenkonferenz empfiehlt das.
Empfiehlt was?
Die Verwendung des Deutschen in den grundständigen Studiengängen. Sie empfiehlt das wortreich. Aber nicht mit dem starken politischen Willen, das auch durchzusetzen sozusagen. Sie schlagen keinen Krach. Das ist nicht ihre Art. Und die Kultusministerkonferenz, wenn Sie so was nehmen oder das Wissenschaftsministerium oder so, die kringeln doch da in der Beziehung, die trauen sich das gar nicht, anzufassen. Und unter den Kollegen, also wenn Sie auf so eine Veranstaltung gehen, über Deutsch als Wissenschaftssprache, gibt es ja immer wieder, da gibt es eben sehr viele, die sagen, ich nicht, ich bin internationalisiert, wie komme ich dazu, ist doch alles Provinzialismus. Ist natürlich ein Totschlagargument. Da brauchen Sie nicht weiter zu argumentieren. Nur ihr Englisch ist meistens nicht so gut. Also meiner Meinung nach, wenn wir über Sprache reden und über was praktisches, hier haben wir auch was praktisches, wenn wir uns alle einig wären, vom Max-Planck-Instituten, von den Max-Planck-Instituten bis über die Rektorenkonferenz bis zu den anderen Hochschulorganisationen, dann ließe sich da was machen. Politisch ist es und von den Kosten her ist es nicht unrealistisch. Die FAZ hat mich da mal mit zitiert und hat gesagt, dann wurde er gleich gefragt, wer soll denn das durchsetzen und dann hat er doch tatsächlich gesagt, wer Bologna durchsetzen kann und die Rechtschreibreform, der wird das ja wohl auch können, wenn er will.
Was genau durchsetzen?
Na das Grundstudium im Allgemeinen auf deutsch.
Ach so die Forderung.
Da wird immer gesagt, das ist doch politisch undenkbar. Bologna ist politisch undenkbar eigentlich, was den Unis da zugemutet worden ist. Und wenn ich in Frankreich über die deutsche Orthografiereform gesprochen habe damals, als es soweit war, da sind die aufgesprungen und haben gesagt, - die Germanisten – wir geben das Deutsche auf, wenn ihr das macht. Diese schriftbewusste Kultur. Wir schreiben einen Brief an den Bundeskanzler. Haben sie rum randaliert, die haben das überhaupt nicht verstanden, was wir da für einen Blödsinn machen.
Die Franzosen sind in die Revolte gegangen, weil die Deutschen eine Rechtschreibreform angestrebt haben?
Das haben sie so gesagt in der Aufregung. Und haben sich vorgestellt, das würde im Französischen passieren, da geraten die in Panik. Die Chinesen übrigens auch. Ich war lange in Peking. Sie sehen, ich bin also ziemlich rum gekommen. Und da habe ich das auch vorgetragen an der Peking-Universität, was die hier vor haben, als es noch nicht so weit war. Und da haben die Panik gekriegt. Die haben gesagt, das muss man sich mal vorstellen hier in China. Alles Schrift determiniert, die ganze Wahrnehmung und dann haben die so eine schöne Orthografie, ist eine der besten überhaupt, die es gibt und dann vergreifen die sich dran. Nein, muss doch verboten werden.
Ja es wird immer so eine Panik verbreitet, so das Deutsche wäre ja irgendwie so schwierig und so kompliziert und das könnte jetzt gar keiner mehr lernen und deswegen müsste das jetzt mal einfacher gemacht werden. Das war ja glaube ich im Kern so ein bisschen die Formulierung. Wie soll man denn das noch lernen, das ist ja alles so kompliziert, deswegen muss man das jetzt mal in der Schreibung nochmal neu greifen. So ein richtiger Erfolg war das ja eigentlich nicht diese Rechtschreibreform. Ist die nicht sogar weitgehend wieder zurückgenommen worden? Ich habe das jetzt nicht...
Ja zum großen Teil.
Ich glaube, das weiß auch kein Mensch so richtig, was dabei raus gekommen ist. Haben sie jetzt nicht mehr Verunsicherung geschaffen?
Wir haben sie von der Deutschen Akademie aus ja teilweise rückgebaut im Jahr 2006. Und was die Orthografiefehler betrifft, da wurden ja Thesen vertreten, dass sie um bis zu 30% abnehmen würden, besonders bei den dummen, bei den schlechten Schülern. Und was ist passiert? Sie haben zugenommen und zwar erheblich. Weil sie einfach gegen das natürliche Schreiben verstoßen haben. Sie haben nicht gewusst, wie weit in der deutschen Orthografie, wie sie sich entwickelt hatte, das Sprachgefühl zum Tragen kommt. Dass also der Deutsche ein sicheres Gefühl dafür entwickelt – oder die deutsche Sprachgemeinschaft – das man „im Allgemeinen“ klein schreiben kann, weil es kein Substantiv ist, weil Sie da kein Adjektiv zusetzen können und gar nichts, ist halt keins. Ist kein richtiger Artikel, sondern nur diese komische Verschmelzungsform. Und diese Intuition, die die Sprachgemeinschaft kollektiv entwickelt, die hat sich in der deutschen Orthografie geradezu genial ausgewirkt. Wenn man das rekonstruiert wissenschaftlich, da kann man nur den Hut ziehen und sagen, ja hinterm Rücken des Einzelnen hat sich hier ein rationaler Prozess vollzogen. Jetzt kommen diese sogenannten Experten und deuteln daran rum und sagen, wir sagen mal, was ein Substantiv ist, nicht die Sprache, wir sagen es. Das ist schief gegangen, musste. Wir haben ihnen das auch vorausgesagt, wir haben ihnen das vorausgesagt.
Ich habe auch – muss ich sagen – ich bin ja nun auch mit der alten Schreibung oder der ursprünglichen Schreibung groß geworden und mich hat diese Rechtschreibreform also auch bis auf sehr sehr sehr wenige Ausnahmen auch extrem verunsichert. Dieser Wahn, Worte auf biegen und brechen auseinander zu kloppen, die vorher zusammengeschrieben wurden. Wo es dann häufig so Konstellationen gab, jetzt habe ich kein Beispiel parat, auf jeden die auseinander geschriebenen Worte bedeuteten für mich auf einmal was ganz anderes, als wenn das zusammen geschrieben wurde.
Genau, fleischfressende Pflanze.
Ja genau. Gutes Beispiel.
Ja aber das haben wir ja weitgehend bereinigt.
Ist das so?
Ja. Nur wenn Sie erst mal die Verunsicherung in der Sprachgemeinschaft drin haben, kriegen Sie sie nicht mehr so schnell raus.
Ja eben.
Also das war so richtig was, wo sich der Systematiker und der Sprachverliebte so richtig auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt hat, als sie das gemacht haben. Und wir haben doch lange dran auch politisch dran argumentiert. Das hat zehn Jahre gedauert bis wesentliches, nicht alles, aber wesentliches rückgebaut wurde. Und wenn es eine solche öffentliche Debatte auch in Bezug auf die Verwendung des Deutschen in den Curricula an den Universitäten und Fachhochschulen gäbe, wäre da was zu erreichen. Aber diese Einigkeit, die ist nicht herzustellen. Leider.
Na gut, nehmen wir es, wie es ist. Jetzt haben wir auch viel über das Erhaltenswürdige gesprochen und dass es doch keine schlechte Idee ist, das Deutsche auch aktiv zu lehren, zu verwenden und dass sich das auch nicht unbedingt widerspricht mit einer weltoffenen Verwendung von Englisch an all den Stellen, wo es angemessen ist. Jetzt wollte ich nochmal so ganz kurz so ein bisschen in die Zukunft der Sprache blicken. Deutsch ist eine lebendige Sprache, ist nicht so, dass wir jetzt irgendwie festharren und Rechtschreibreform hat nicht geklappt, jetzt ändert sich irgendwie gar nichts mehr, sondern die Einflüsse sind da, die Verquickung mit anderen Sprachen ist da und ich denke, das Internet insbesondere bringt jetzt hier noch einen ganz neue Qualität mit sich. Inwiefern merken Sie das – ich meine Sie forschen jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr so aktiv, aber – was steht an fürs Deutsche? Was passiert?
Also für so einen wie mich stellt sich die Frage in der Form, wird das geschriebene Standarddeutsche, das ja das Lernziel für den muttersprachlichen Unterricht ist, wird das geschriebene Standarddeutsch noch über Generationen hinweg in ungefähr derselben Form Allgemeingut bleiben? Weil am geschriebenen Standard hängt eigentlich alles. Das ist der gemeinsame Bezugspunkt für die gesamte Sprachgemeinschaft und der kann nicht ersetzt werden ohne weiteres, dieser gemeinsame Bezugspunkt, durch irgendeine engere Varietät, wie sie zum Beispiel die Sprache in den sozialen Medien oder überhaupt die Internetsprache, die E-Mail-Sprache oder so etwas, das sind Sprachformen, die es von der Funktion in vergleichbarer Weise durchaus schon früher gegeben hat, wenn auch nicht in dem Umfang, also die Jugendsprache, Studentensprache hat eine lange Geschichte im Deutschen und hatte immer auch die Funktion, die Gruppe abzugrenzen. Aber es ist wohl tatsächlich so, dass mit den elektronischen Medien diese Sprachformen, die auch in sich nicht alle gleich sind, weite Verbreitung finden und große Gruppen erfassen. Wie weit sie die Jugendlichen oder die Computerbenutzer daran hindern, noch das Standarddeutsch zu beherrschen und in entsprechenden Kontexten auch zu verwenden, ist mindestens teilweise ungeklärt bis heute. Und es wird ganz wesentlich auch, wie langsam das geht oder wie schnell das geht oder ob überhaupt da ein Damm aufgebaut werden kann. Es ist ja kein Nachteil für einen Hauptschüler und erst recht nicht für einen Gymnasiasten, wenn er nach Verlassen der Schule das Deutsche in Wort und Schrift, das Standarddeutsche gut beherrscht, das ist ja kein Nachteil für seine weitere berufliche Entwicklung, sondern nur ein Vorteil. Insofern ist die Schule auch verpflichtet, das hinzukriegen. Da genügt es nicht, wenn man eben das Schreiben von Bewerbungen übt, was ja immer gemacht wird, sondern die müssen sich schon ausdrücken können und einigermaßen korrekt, jedenfalls soweit, dass, wenn sie Zweifel haben, sie ein Rechtschreibwörterbuch aufschlagen oder richtiges und gutes Deutsch aufschlagen oder irgend etwas, dass sie sich da zurechtfinden. Sie müssen sich irgendwie im Standard zurechtfinden, müssen da zu Hause sein. Also das wird ganz wesentlich davon abhängen, wie sich die Lehrerausbildung entwickelt. Wenn die Universitäten darauf bestehen, dass die Deutschlehrer ganz besonders, aber auch die Fachlehrer, zumindest wenn wir mal die Grundschule nehmen oder aber auch, wenn wir die Gesamtschule nehmen oder das Gymnasium nehmen, dass die Lehrer dieses Ziel weiter verfolgen im Deutschunterricht. Wenn wir ihnen auch so viel beibringen, dass sie das können an den Unis, dann hat das Deutsche in diesem Sinne noch eine lange Geschichte vor sich. Weil es eben auch so natürlich und so leicht zu lernen ist. Und dieses Gerücht, dass das Deutsche eine schwere Sprache ist, das ist ein übles Gerücht seit Mark Twain oder auch noch aus noch älteren Zeiten immer wieder kolportiert wird von Leuten, die keine Lust haben, das zu lernen. Französisch ist viel schwerer.
Warum?
Wegen des Unterschieds zum Gesprochenen.
Nur deswegen?
Ja, das ist halt konservativ das geschriebene Französisch. Das Deutsche ist eine moderne Sprache. Die ist in bestimmter Hinsicht konservativer als das Englische, was aber eben einer weitgehend vom Staat unbeeinflussten natürlichen Entwicklung geschuldet ist. Und nicht einer Verordnung einer bestimmten Sprachform. Also wenn Sie das durch das 19. Jahrhundert verfolgen, wie sich das vereinheitlicht hat und was dabei noch verändert wurde, dann, habe ich ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, dann staunen Sie nur, wie gut das gelaufen ist, wie vernünftig das gelaufen ist. Und das Ergebnis kann sich sehen lassen und kann sich auch vermitteln lassen. Also ich habe ungefähr, um das auch mal von der Seite zu beleuchten – ich weiß nicht genau – 15 oder 18 Auslandsprofessuren hinter mich gebracht in meinem wissenschaftlichen Leben – in Thailand und sonst wo – und es gab kein Land, in dem der Erwerb der deutschen Schriftsprache, also der Orthografie, ein besonderes Problem dargestellt hat. Wenn die die Phonetik, die Wortbildung und die Syntax gelernt haben, ist die Orthografie dabei abgefallen. Und ich habe wirklich gesucht, ich sollte da einen Aufsatz schreiben, habe ich auch gemacht, für das Jahrbuch „Deutsch als Fremdsprache“.
Ist die Grammatik nicht die eigentliche Herausforderung? Die Fälle, die ganzen Wortendungen?
Das ist alles so logisch. Wenn Sie es richtig machen. Sie müssen natürlich eine gute Didaktik dafür haben. Das richtige Material präsentieren. Das ist alles so logisch. Kommt so natürlich und entwickelt sich so natürlich.
Was haben denn die Studenten oder Schüler, mit denen Sie gearbeitet haben, für eine Beziehung zu der Sprache entwickelt. Wie sieht man das Deutsche als Ausländer.
In Berlin und in Potsdam?
Nein, Thailand, Ägypten, China, all die Länder, die Sie gerade genannt haben, die Studenten, die dort in ihrem eigenen Land Deutsch als Fremdsprache lernen, was begeistert die?
Also das hat ganz verschiedene Motivationen. In Teheran war es so, dass es dort sehr alte Beziehungen gibt zu Westeuropa. Zu Deutschland, zu Frankreich, zu anderen auch. Und das waren so mit die besten Studenten, die ich überhaupt gesehen habe. Die hatten einfach den ausgeprägten Willen, diese Sprache zu lernen, um die Literatur zu lesen, um vielleicht auch mal in Deutschland zu studieren, um die Sprache zu können. Weil Deutschland hat in vielen Ländern der Erde ein hohes Prestige. Kulturell, technisch. Also gerade das Technische, das war zum Beispiel von ganz großer Bedeutung in Thailand. Dort wurde mir immer wieder erzählt, dass ThaiAir nur so gut sei, weil Lufthansa die Piloten ausgebildet hätte. Und wenn Sie in eine Druckerei gehen, ich sage jetzt mal was ganz gefährliches, ich gehe nachts – mach ich Spaziergänge - durch Bangkok und komme an einer Druckerei vorbei, hell erleuchtet, wird gedruckt, stehen fünf Druckmaschinen, davon laufen drei, steht dann Heideldruck. Bei den anderen beiden steht es nicht. Und der deutsche Maschinenbau in China spielt eine riesige Rolle. Und als ich in China das erste Mal, das war 1988, also direkt vor Tian’anmen, an der Peking-Universität. Da spielte das kombinatorische Denken, was Sie lernen, wenn Sie lernen, wie Wörter im Geschriebenen aus Buchstaben und aus Silben und aus Morphemen aufgebaut sind und dann wie aus Wörtern Phrasen und Sätze aufgebaut sind. Im Chinesischen gibt es diese Art von Kombinatorik fast gar nicht. Und das war eine Denkform, die galt als subversiv in China zu der Zeit. Das war so. Die haben es mir aus der Hand gefressen, irgendwann wurde ich zum Dekan bestellt und da wurde mir gesagt, die Studenten hätten sich beschwert, dass sie nichts verstehen, das Gegenteil war wahr. In Ägypten gab es - da war ich eben wie gesagt an der Al Asa-Univesität sogar - eine sehr starke Motivation Deutsch zu lernen, weil Deutsch unter anderem nicht belastet war, wie das Englische und das Französische, politisch, historisch. Allerdings dann wieder mit der Kehrseite, man wollte mich unbedingt nach El Alamein bringen und sagen, hier guck mal, der Wüstenfuchs Rommel das war doch noch ein Kerl. Das kommt Ihnen auch unter. Das kommt Ihnen in Japan auch unter. Da hat das Deutsche ein großes Ansehen. Einmal weil ich im 19. Jahrhundert das deutsche Rechtssystem importiert worden ist nach Japan und einen sehr großen Einfluss hatte auf das japanische Rechtswesen und auf die Kultur im Allgemeinen. Und deswegen bis heute ein hohes Ansehen hat, aber da gibt es jetzt auch die Kehrseite. So ist es nicht über einen Leisten zu schlagen. Manchmal ist es auch so gewesen, dass ich mich geärgert habe, wenn ich irgendwo war, wo die Philologien alle vertreten waren und ich gesehen habe, wie zum Beispiel, wie selbstbewusst das Personal das Französische vertreten hat. Und wie ängstlich oder wenig selbstbewusst das deutsche Personal sein Deutsch vertreten hat. Weil sie aus Deutschland nur hören, das Deutsche ist übermorgen schon am Ende und eine sterbende Sprache, dann war das so, warum?
Selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung.
In Europa ist das Deutsche größer als das Französische. Was? Glaubt einem da erst mal keiner. Und warum vertretet ihr eure Sache nicht genauso? Das ist ganz toll, wie die Franzosen das machen, da könnt ihr was von lernen, also wie die Romanisten das machen. So war das sehr durchmischt von der Denkform, auf die Sie stoßen bis zu den praktischen Gründen. Aber die Denkform war auch immer wieder wichtig. Nie so wichtig, wie in China. Also diese Faszination, dass man mit 26-30 Buchstaben vier Millionen Wörter schreiben kann.
Und nicht so viele komplizierte Zeichen dafür braucht.
Ja.
Sprache formt das Denken.
Das ist ein Aspekt dieser.
Das ist definitiv ein Aspekt, der hier mehrfach schon zur Sprache kam. Herr Eisenberg, vielen Dank für die Reise durchs Deutsche. Fand ich sehr spannend. Viele Aspekte aufgebracht, an die auch selber noch nicht so gedacht habe und jetzt können wir wieder alle ins Deutsche entlassen. Vor allem auch die Wissenschaftler, die zuhören.
Das wäre ja zu schön. Einige würden sich angeregt fühlen.
Das haben wir ja hier zumindest vor. Also nochmal vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Und ja vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war die 7. Ausgabe hier vom Forschergeist, geht in ein paar Wochen auch wieder weiter. Wir hören uns, bis bald.